by the way is there something
interesting to say about your world view
because you mentioned psychic and
in sort of the ways we can be healthy
the ways we can
grown how much maybe medicine or science
or has
um has the answers
is there is there some interesting way
to describe that worldview i would just
say i'm open mind i believe anything is
possible
and if i was going to trust in any
practical information it would be
something thousands of years old
there's wisdom in that history yeah well
it's it's more
tested it's not always right
but it's at least
it's been somewhat tested though science
is also tested
the the thing i'm a little bit skeptical
of sometimes is just the hubris that
often comes with the modern with the
latest the newest the this this feeling
like you figured it all out everything
that's been done in the past has no
wisdom
and uh we basically solved every problem
oh you know there's nothing else to be
solved this i mean that's the defining
characteristic of any age is like we've
solved all the problems there are we've
have the final answers
and our parents are all stupid
that kind of energy yeah and that you
have to be extremely extremely careful
with that when it talks about when you
think about something as complex as the
human body or the human mind it could be
very
very very i believe we know
close to nothing yeah exactly close to
nothing that's about anything
about anything about any that place of
humility is a good place to start to
figure to figure it all out and in the
end we'll still know almost nothing yeah
i don't think we need to know
it's like we need to see what works so
we need to see what works for us
it's interesting to know i i know on the
art side
knowing how it works isn't what makes it
work you know isn't the magic of it
isn't how it works the magic is the
magic
and
the magic happens in a way that's
intuitive
and accidental at times
or uh
incidental where you're trying many
things all of a sudden something works
and um and you don't know why
and it's okay not to know why it doesn't
matter it doesn't really matter why as
long as it does the thing that you want
it to do whatever that is
yeah that's so weird when you know the
components you don't
you still yeah the magic what's the
magic where's the magic like we know the
components for stuff i care about
artificial intelligence we know the
components
of a powerful computing machinery where
does consciousness come from
what is that
uh where does the uh
uh brilliant
moments of insight come from what's that
when uh even in simple games of chess or
in simple
words of those breakthrough ideas
of taking the big risk that doesn't make
any sense and then all of a sudden it
becomes something beautiful yeah we
don't need to understand why it just
happens it just happens and often the
things that end up breaking through
don't break through in the way we
thought or
turn out to be a third iteration of
something that we thought was an
entirely different thing or
we don't know you know it's and i i
think it's
if we embrace that not knowing we'll
have a
healthier experience going through life
you